[Musique]
voilà c'est parti pour un nouveau stream
sur la société et sur Youtube alors dans
ce stream moi j'ai envie de partager
avec vous c'est pas la publications
OK
ça me semble correct
ça marche bon super donc l'idée de ces
stream c'est que quand on fait des
sciences sociales on va se s'orienter
vers des bouquins et on passe peut-être
à côté de ce que sont les sciences
sociales de ce qu'est la recherche en
sciences sociales donc moi l'idée de ces
streams c'est vraiment de partager avec
vous des articles scientifiques à mon
sens c'est ce qui se rapporte le plus de
la recherche moi je suis pas chercheur
sur social j'ai juste prof dans le
secondaire et donc voilà c'est comme si
j'expliquais finalement aux élèves ce
que sont des articles scientifiques
publiés dans des revues de sciences
sociales scientifiques donc ça c'est
vraiment le
l'idée l'objectif de de ces streams ici
c'est d'aborder ensemble des articles
voilà de la recherche alors ici j'ai
sélectionné un article qui est pas du
tout sexy au niveau du thème parce que
c'est limite très très chiant mais
j'avais vraiment envie de le faire parce
que ça fait écho à l'actualité en
Belgique
et donc ça m'intéressait assez bien et
c'est un article qui est issu de la
revue française de sociologie alors il
faut savoir qu'il y a plein de revues en
sciences sociales et la plus célèbre
j'ai envie de dire ça comme ça c'est
celle-ci c'est la revue française de
sociologie c'est dans celle-là quand on
fait des classements et qu'on regarde où
les chercheurs français publient le plus
c'est là où on publie plus c'est celle
qui est aussi la plus cité alors j'avais
fait un petit tableau pour voir dans
tous les streams que j'ai déjà fait si
j'avais plus parlé de cette revue là et
il se trouve que c'est pas une revue que
j'ai beaucoup utilisé l'année dernière
et donc c'était l'occasion alors c'est
une revue qui est assez exigeante et il
y a beaucoup de statistiques et ça ça
m'intéressait aussi parce que j'aime
bien montrer que les sciences sociales
c'est c'est aussi principalement des
statistiques quand en tout cas on fait
des méthodes quantitatives alors ici
l'article il a été
rédigé par deux auteurs Fernando Nunez
Rogero et Pascal Bressoux alors tout
surtout en rangeant un peu ici le studio
pour le stream je me suis rendu compte
que Pascal bressous c'est un gars que
j'avais déjà lu dans ce bouquin-ci
modélisation statistique appliquée aux
séances sociales alors là on a un
bouquin de stats vraiment pour la
science sociale moi j'ai fait science
politique on a eu quelques cours
d'analyse des données on a eu quelques
cours de statistiques mais c'était pas
vraiment le focus qui était fait et je
trouvais que j'avais vraiment des
lacunes en statistique j'ai un peu
retravaillé ça en autodidacte ici c'est
vraiment un bouquin j'avoue qui est
assez dense
j'ai repris d'autres bouquins mais pour
vous dire que Pascal Bressoux c'est
vraiment une bête pour tout ce qui est
statistique en sciences sociales et ça
fait du bien de voir aussi des séances
sociales avec des méthodes quantitatives
parce que parfois on pourrait penser que
les sciences sociales c'est juste du
blabla que les sciences sociales il y a
rien de rigoureux dans tout ça alors que
c'est pas le cas évidemment c'est plus
difficile de faire des méthodes
quantitatives à mon sens que des
méthodes qualitatives parce que méthode
quantitative il y a vraiment une
technique statistiques à maîtriser et
j'aimerais aussi démystifier ça dans ce
dans ce stream en vous montrant que
c'est pas parce que on ne maîtrise pas
tout qu'on ne peut pas comprendre
il y a le faire et puis il y a le livre
nous on ne fait ici que le lire moi mon
but c'est pas de faire des gens qui
suivent les streams évidemment des
professionnels des sciences sociales
c'est juste qu'on puisse y avoir accès
il donnait accès c'est vraiment un souci
de vulgarisation donc
ce qu'on va faire je vais lire l'article
alors je veux pas le diffuser en direct
parce que j'ai pas les les droits mais
vous retrouvez toutes les infos dans le
descriptif de la vidéo avec les liens
vers la plateforme Kern la plateforme
Kern c'est une plateforme qui reprend
beaucoup de d'éditeurs donc on va
retrouver beaucoup de revues de sciences
sociales qui qui sont présentés les
articles depuis trois ans sont
généralement consolation libre mais les
articles plus récents sont payants par
contre si vous êtes dans une fac et bien
vous pouvez y avoir normalement accès ça
il faut se renseigner dans votre fac
pour y avoir accès gratuitement c'est
assez intéressant mais je vous le
montrerai quand même quelques éléments
voilà ça c'est pour ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui c'est parti et le titre de
l'article vous le voyez ici à l'écran
c'est évaluer l'action éducative des
lycées à travers les ivals
quand le bruit s'imisse dans
l'administration de la preuve
je vais pas introduire parce que ça va
être ça va être dit
alors il faut savoir qu'en Belgique on
est aussi dans un processus comme ça on
va tenter d'évaluer ce que font les
établissements scolaires en plus en
Belgique actuellement on parle de
l'évaluation des enseignants ça c'est un
autre volet ici on parle vraiment de
d'évaluer ce que font les écoles est-ce
que les écoles font bien leur job ou pas
alors on va voir que ça pose plein de
questions évidemment ici avec l'article
les indicateurs de performance des
établissements scolaires constituent des
objets d'analyses controversés de la
sociologie de l'éducation oui parce
qu'on peut se dire est-ce qu'on peut
mesurer ça c'est la grande question
ils ont en effet pour objectif d'établir
le rôle joué par un établissement dans
l'explication des phénomènes éducatifs
fondamentaux pour l'insertion sociale et
professionnelle c'est aussi un intérêt
pour le pilotage comment tu fais pour
diriger ton école pour que les profs
puissent agir dans leur école si ils ne
savent pas où ils en sont donc ça a un
intérêt aussi pour le pilotage en
Belgique c'est surtout pour ça qu'on
utilise des indicateurs de l'action
scolaire enfin de l'efficacité scolaire
c'est pour faire des plans de pilotage
justement pour que les établissements
scolaires puissent diriger
convenablement leur action alors voilà
je ne juge pas c'est toujours le
principe des sciences sociales il faut
jamais trop juger c'est pas ça le but ce
qu'on essaie de faire c'est de
comprendre
et donc on va tenter d'évaluer avec ces
indicateurs leur efficacité globale
est-ce que les écoles sont efficaces
évidemment
construire des indicateurs de ce type
qui vont nous donner une indication une
synthèse finalement chiffrée de l'effet
de l'efficacité des établissements c'est
assez difficile à construire et surtout
à interpréter on va voir comment en
France on s'y est pris le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale publie chaque
année trois indicateurs de valeur
ajoutée des lycées donc indicateur de
valeur ajoutée des lycées
Ival
Ival concernant le taux de réussite le
taux de mention et le taux d'accès au
baccalauréat et donc on voit qu'en
France on a pris le parti de évaluer
uniquement le résultat final en termes
de baccalauréat est-ce que les élèves
est-ce que les étudiants les élèves
plutôt vont avoir leur bac comment
est-ce qu'ils vont l'avoir avec le taux
de mention
et le taux d'accès
cette limite qui en fait que par
construction les ivals mystérielles
ignorent une erreur d'échantillonnage
qui confond dans la valeur ajoutée des
lycées les faits de leur propre action
avec les effets du hasard et l'on voit
tout l'enjeu est-ce que le résultat en
termes de taux de réussite au
baccalauréat est-ce que c'est
lié forcément à l'action des lycées
est-ce qu'il y a pas des facteurs
extérieurs qui vont intervenir ce qu'ils
appellent ici dans l'article bruit
parce qu'on pourrait se dire voilà dans
cette école on a un taux incroyable de
réussite dans cette école on a un taux
très très faible voilà si on fait un peu
de sciences sociales on sait directement
bien que le contexte socio-économique va
jouer beaucoup on va voir que tout ça
évidemment est un peu plus réfléchi mais
c'est un petit peu l'enjeu si vous
voulez c'est est-ce que on peut faire
confiance à ces indicateurs comme seul
finalement seul élément qui nous
permettent d'évaluer l'action des lycées
alors illustrant l'importance de ce
bruit donc tous les facteurs qui ne
seraient pas dû à l'action des lycées
mais qui vont impacter le taux de
réussite illustrant l'importance de ce
bruit et la précarité des évaluations
qui ont découle pour de nombreux lycées
cet article propose des méthodes
d'estimation alternatives permettant de
contrôler les effets du hasard afin
d'obtenir une information plus fiable
sur l'action éducative des lycées alors
c'est assez intéressant ici parce que on
voit que les auteurs veulent avoir
une force de proposition et c'est pas
toujours le cas quand on fait des
séances sociales il y a pas toujours des
solutions qui sont proposées à la fin
parce que la démarche scientifique c'est
surtout comprendre
la démarche scientifique en sciences
sociales c'est aussi comprendre donc
c'est pas ce qu'on comprend que
forcément on est normatif à la fin en
disant il faut faire ceci il faut faire
cela mais ici voilà il y a un côté
praxéologique comme on le dit donc ils
vont proposer des pistes pour les
praticiens pour ceux qui font qui sont
dans la pratique pour qu'ils puissent
l'appliquer donc c'est aussi intéressant
de ce point de vue là parce qu'on va
voir concrètement comment est-ce qu'ils
vont s'y prendre
alors les indicateurs les ivals les
fameuses ivals ici fournissent aux
acteurs de terrain un outil d'évaluation
fiable et accessible permettant
d'implémenter une culture d'action
fondée sur la preuve donc c'est ça
l'idée c'est on va prouver que l'action
du lycée existe est efficace ou pas mais
de quelle preuve est-il question
exactement
et tout ce qu'on veut en fait évaluer
ici c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet
établissement est-ce que l'établissement
scolaire en tant que tel a une action à
une influence sur la réussite scolaire
parce que voilà il y a des éléments qui
sont dus au contexte familial le
contexte socio-économique qui va jouer
sur la réussite scolaire il y a aussi
l'effet de l'enseignant il y a aussi la
motivation intrinsèque de l'élève mais
ici ce qu'on veut cibler c'est l'effet
des établissements
et donc là il y a tout un tout un
historique évidemment et c'est un peu
une revue de la littérature donc les
auteurs vont un petit peu passer en
revue ce qui a été fait par rapport à
cet objet là donc l'effet établissement
les établissements ont-ils un effet
spécifique sur un site scolaire des
élèves au cours des années 60 les
premières études affirmèrent la quasi
inexistence des effets d'établissement
school make nodifférence en montrant que
les moyens financiers à louer aux écoles
les dotations qu'elles soient
matérielles ou humaines n'impactez pas
ou très faiblement les acquisitions
cognitives des élèves donc dans les
années 60 voilà on pense vraiment qu'il
y a aucun lien entre les deux au
contraire le milieu social d'origine des
élèves et le contexte social qui en
découlé jouait des rôles les plus
déterminants et ici on fait référence
aux fameux rapport Coolman donc
l'emblématique rapport Coleman si vous
avez fait un peu de sociologie
d'éducation voilà c'est des grandes
analyses qu'on a faites aux États-Unis
de justement de de l'impact
de différents facteurs sur la réussite
scolaire des élèves alors je sais plus
le détailler ce serait peut-être
intéressant une fois de refaire un
stream pour reparler de la sociologie de
l'éducation c'est vraiment un sujet
assez passionnant si des inégalités de
moyens existaient bel et bien d'une
école à une autre c'est inégalités ne
permettaient pas d'expliquer les
différences de réussite entre les élèves
par opposition au premier travaux les
tenants de l'efficacité de l'école
school effective
contestèrent dans les années
70-70 et 80 l'assimilé l'assimilation
des effets d'établissement donc une
décennie plus tard on fait marche
arrière et les études montrent que ça a
quand même un impact
plus qu'une unité de production
déterminée par ses intrants
institutionnels les moyens financiers
l'école serait une entité sociale dont
l'efficacité tiendrait à la cohérence de
son fonctionnement interne donc dans les
années 70 les années 80 on se rend
compte que ça peut avoir un effet que
l'école en tant que tel l'établissement
scolaire impact la réussite de ses
élèves
alors ici c'est intéressant parce que
voilà on essaie de rompre évidemment
avec les prénoms avec tout ce qu'on peut
penser voilà peut-être que vous vous
pensez que l'école l'établissement
scolaire ne influence pas et que c'est
juste la motivation de l'élève ou
peut-être que c'est le milieu familial
qui va favoriser quand on fait des
sciences sociales à se loger on essaie
de faire une vraiment une rupture par
rapport à tout ça et de garder la tête
froide et d'essayer de mettre un petit
peu tout ce qu'on pense les opinions on
sait jamais facile mais dans une boîte
et de les laisser bien là tranquille et
d'essayer de voir un petit peu si quels
ont été les études précédentes qui nous
permettent un petit peu de de rectifier
les billets qu'on aurait nous-même quoi
si c'est jamais évident
donc c'est pour ça qu'on fait aussi
cette revue de la littérature à partir
des années 90-90 le débat se focalisait
davantage sur la nature des effets
établissements afin de savoir dans
quelle mesure l'action éducative était
indépendante ou non du public accueilli
et donc là on essaie de voir les
interactions entre l'établissement et le
public est-ce que c'est vraiment lié à
l'action de l'établissement
indépendamment de son public parce
qu'évidemment si tu es dans un lycée
dans une école précarisée il va y avoir
un effet d'établissement mais qui est
lié en fait à ton public mais est-ce
qu'il y a une action propre aux
établissements c'est ce qu'on
s'intéresse plus à ça dans les années 90
alors vous voyez que ici en fait il y a
des modes il y a des modes qui passent
en termes de recherche on a des
paradigmes dans lesquels on s'engouffre
des problématiques qui vont être plus
étudiées que d'autres dans certaines
décennies des études par exemple ont par
exemple montré que les enseignants
s'adressant à des élèves issus de milieu
défavorisés plutôt que favorisés passe
davantage de temps à gérer des problèmes
discip en classe font moins confiance en
la capacité à apprendre et à réussir des
élèves et ont des objectifs
d'apprentissage moins ambitieux ce qui
se solde par des apprentissages plus
modestes et par un risque plus élevé de
décrochage scolaire et donc là c'est
intéressant est-ce que c'est l'histoire
de la poulet de l'oeuf est-ce que c'est
parce qu'on a un public précarisé qu'on
a de moins bons résultats ou alors
est-ce que c'est parce que il y a aussi
des représentations qui sont véhiculées
par les enseignants qui vont justement
prendre
les élèves qu'ils ont ça eux pour des
teubés ou qui vont avoir certains a
priori qui vont faire qui vont être
moins exigeants que s'ils avaient été
dans un lycée avec un public plus
favorisé c'est très intéressant on a
envie et chaque fois évidemment il y a
des références qui sont précisées que je
ne vous cite pas mais ça fait référence
à plein d'auteurs qui sont dans la
bibliographie et donc quand on fait une
recherche on pourrait se contenter par
exemple de cette revue la littérature
pour soit moins soi-même aller voir les
différentes ressources qui sont
intéressantes par rapport à cet objet
d'étude
alors moi c'est toujours le problème
c'est que comme je j'adore tout ça
je vais voir après certains articles et
puis après je n'avance pas dans la
lecture de mon article donc ici j'avais
notamment téléchargé un des articles qui
avait été cité mais j'ai été rigoureux
et j'ai essayé d'avoir une certaine
discipline de rester sur la lecture de
cet article si parce que tu vois tu peux
vite partir dans les différents dans les
différentes pistes qui te sont lancées
quoi ce genre de constat suggère que
l'effet de l'action éducative d'un
établissement est au moins en partie
indépendante des profils des élèves
accueillis et des processus qui en
découlent
voilà donc ça c'est un petit peu
le contexte de la recherche dans
laquelle on s'inscrit ici
et là on va s'intéresser vraiment
à la mesure de l'action éducative des
établissements dans la lignée des
travaux sur les effets établissements
les ivals ont été introduites en France
afin de distinguer l'effet de l'action
éducative d'un établissement ça va leur
intrinsèque aussi appelée valeur ajoutée
ou sa performance donc on veut on veut
vraiment mesurer la performance des
lycées par rapport aux effets de
facteurs exogènes tels que sa
composition socio-académique où son
offre de formation sa valeur extrinsèque
associée à une réputation sociale
sur lesquels l'établissement n'a que peu
d'emprise et qui relève avant tout de
déterminisme socio-historique on
séductif du marché scolaire et de la
carte scolaire si l'outil de mesure
visait clair sa réalisation est plus
difficile donc on essaie vraiment de
d'écarter tout ce qui est périphérique à
l'établissement pour ne garder que ce
qui est propre à l'établissement donc
son action en fait ce qu'il propose en
termes de structure en termes de
fonctionnement en effet relié un modèle
statistique de la réussite scolaire à
l'action éducative d'un établissement
n'est pas anodin d'un point de vue de
l'inférence causale alors la référence
causale c'est justement de retrouver les
causes d'une conséquence est-ce que on a
juste une corrélation ou est-ce que le
phénomène qu'on a en amont et bien la
cause de celui qu'on en aval quoi
parfois on a des phénomènes qui varient
en même temps mais qui ne sont pas dans
un rapport de causalité qui sont juste
dans un rapport de corrélation style le
niveau de lecture des élèves
et leur pointure varie en même temps
c'est un exemple qu'on reprend souvent
peut constater que plus la taille des
chaussures des élèves est grande en
primaire plus leur niveau de lecture est
important mais il y a aucune cause en
fait c'est juste la cause c'est une
cause unique qui est l'âge et donc là on
voit bien que ces deux variables-là la
pointure et le niveau de lecture varie
en même temps mais c'est parce qu'on a
une cause qu'on n'avait pas identifié
initialement quand je voulais présenter
au départ qui est l'âge des élèves
voilà du fait de déterminisme multiple
ça je l'ai dit
non pardon en effet relié un modèle
statistique de la régie scolaire à
l'action éducative d'un établissement
n'est pas anodin n'a pas vu de la
référence Cazale du fait de déterminisme
multiple ségrégation sociale scolaire
stratégie de scolarisation des parents
inégalités territoriale dans l'offre de
formation bah ouais si tu as qu'un seul
qu'un seul lycée dans ton dans ton coin
qui n'offre que que certaines options
c'est pas la même chose en termes de
d'offres de formation les élèves ne sont
pas répartis de manière aléatoire à
travers les lycées pour parvenir
néanmoins une inférence causale
plausible la méthodologie des ivales
recourt à une stratégie de modélisation
quasi expérimentale consistant à
contrôler les effets des
caractéristiques des élèves et du
contexte socio-scolaire du lycée par
l'intermédiaire de régression de
régression logistique multiniveaux alors
là voilà pour l'instant là on se dit ouh
là là ou dans quoi on part mais ça
franchement c'est du blabla et on va
passer outre
vous allez voir on va tout comprendre
sans avoir forcément compris ce passage
là dans cette stratégie on opère un
calcul des différences entre un taux
prédit par le modèle statistique par
exemple 70% de réussite au baccalauréat
le modèle dit dans ce lycée là on
devrait avoir 70% 70% de réussite au
baccalauréat et
le tour effectivement constaté on
constate qu'il y a 80% de réussite et
donc la différence entre les deux c'est
10% entre ce que le modèle avait prédit
dans ce lycée là en fonction de
différents facteurs on devrait obtenir
cela et on obtient effectivement ceci et
donc la différence entre le cela et ceci
10% mais là c'est 10% positif on se dit
bah voilà c'est l'action du lycée qui a
été positif et qui a permis de
progresser en termes de réussite au
baccalauréat de 10% par rapport à une
situation de départ ou le lycée n'aurait
pas eu d'action significative
j'espère que j'ai été clair si je ne
suis pas clair dites-le dans le chat
j'espère que je vois le chat normalement
il doit s'afficher ici
je vais faire un test
salut le chat comme ça je vais être sûr
que ça fonctionne ça
le chat
voilà ça fonctionne donc je vois des
messages si on a
donc c'est ça qu'on va essayer de faire
et l'enjeu c'est bon on va pas rentrer
dans la recette de comment ce modèle est
fait comment est-ce que le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale comment
l'éducation pardonale va définir ce
modèle ça on ne le sait pas on sait que
il va regarder le public d'origine son
niveau social son niveau
socio-économique il va regarder un peu
tout ça et donc avec un algorithme on va
définir tiens un score
qu'on voilà qu'on devrait obtenir au
baccalauréat quoi mais ça on s'en fout
de savoir comment est-ce qu'ils font
l'important c'est de de comprendre ici
que yasmodel et puis on regarde le
résultat final et on va comparer les
deux
le taux prédit correspond alors à la
somme des effets éducatifs associés aux
facteurs exogènes qui peuvent être
effectivement mesurés ce qui permet de
mettre tous les établissements sur un
pied d'égalité en termes de niveau
attendu oui parce que un lycée qui est
plus précarisé et bien il va avoir un
modèle qui va lui dire que le taux va
être moins important le taux de réussite
au baccalauréat sera moins important que
dans un lycée qui est plus favorisé donc
voilà on va pouvoir comparer tout le
monde puisque celui qui a un public qui
est moins scolaire ben voilà il aura un
score à atteindre qui sera moins élevé
on peut dire ça comme ça la différence
entre le taux attendu les taux constaté
au sein du lycée est alors interprété
comme la valeur ajoutée de
l'établissement sa performance
voilà ça c'est important d'avoir bien
compris ça il y a un modèle et puis on
constate le résultat final au
baccalauréat et on compare par rapport
au score du modèle
l'action éducative d'un établissement
est multidimensionnelle et peut
concerner le développement des
compétences cognitives les savoirs
académiques savoir professionnel des
compétences non cognitives les normes
sociales les comportementales
motivationnels
confiance en soi ça c'est toutes des
choses qu'on ne va pas évaluer avec ces
ivals ou encore des débouchés sociaux
professionnels au niveau des lycées
l'enseignement scolaire français vise
l'obtention d'un diplôme qualifiant vu
de l'insertion professionnelle ou de
l'accès aux études supérieures cet
objectif de qualification justifiant
entre autres par le fait que l'absence
de diplômes est associé à un risque plus
élevé de chômage et de précarité de
l'emploi dans cette optique les Ival ont
été introduits en France en se centrant
sur l'obtention l'obtention du
baccalauréat chez les élèves donc là on
explique pourquoi est-ce qu'on a pris
ces indicateurs là alors qu'ils sont
finalement ils reflètent une réalité qui
est assez limitée puisque on oublie
plein de choses quoi
alors il y a plein de critiques qui ont
été faites de ces ivals bah déjà parce
que ça n'évalue pas tout mais là je
passe les critiques mais c'est mentionné
dans l'article et donc ici on attaque
vraiment le cœur de l'article en nous
disant
qu'il y a du bruit et que
la différence entre le modèle et le
résultat des lycées ce fameux cette
fameuse performance ben en fait on n'est
pas sûr que ça soit vraiment la
performance des lycées c'est peut-être
des effets extérieurs des facteurs
extérieurs qu'on n'a pas évalué qu'on
n'a pas pris en compte et qui viennent
faire du bruit des interférences dans
l'évaluation qu'on veut faire le premier
paramètre concerne le taux théorique de
réussite qui correspond au taux de
réussite observé au sein de la
population générale le second paramètre
concerne la variance d’échantillonnages
autour de ce taux de réussite qui
correspond à un écart systématique
le bruit statistique entre le taux
observé dans la population et le taux
observé dans un échantillon aléatoire de
la population alors tout ça peut
paraître très compliqué mais je vais
tout expliquer ici après
je vais continuer à lire faut juste
accrocher un petit peu ici en théorie
cette équerre systématique est
entièrement dû au hasard et plus
précisément aux variations aléatoires
induites par l'échantillonnage bon on
est bien d'accord que si tu prends
une partie de la population par exemple
tu vas dans une classe et tu prends 5
élèves tu vas peut-être tomber sur cinq
filles mais cinq filles tu auras donc
dans ton échantillon 100% de filles mais
ça veut pas dire que ta population
totale des élèves c'est 100% de filles
quoi il y a le fait que tu as pris un
petit échantillon et que le fait de
prendre un petit échantillon ben ça peut
induire des erreurs si tu veux c'est une
erreur d'échantillonnage évidemment plus
on échantillon va être important si tu
prends la population toute une école
sauf si c'est une école qui est pas
mixte mais dans le cadre d'une école
mixte tu prends les populations toute
une école il y a très peu de chances que
tu es 100% de filles tu vois donc il y a
des problèmes d'échantillonnage
notamment pour les petits établissements
c'est ce qu'on nous explique ici par
exemple des différences de répartition
du genre entre deux échant sortir
ressort donc tu pourras avoir dans un
lycée
51% de filles dans un lycée 48% dans un
autre lycée voilà tu as pas en fait des
points de comparaison entre les deux
lycées parce que si les filles qui se
mieux au baccalauréat pour des questions
voilà de socialisation mais là tu vas
défavoriser le deuxième lycée que tu as
48% de filles se traduiront par des
différences de réussite du baccalauréat
qui seront proportionnels à l'effet du
genre sur la réussite et aux écarts de
répartition observée entre les
échantillons de la population plus
l'échantillonnage sera restreint par
exemple 10 élèves mais il y a des
établissements où il y a très peu
d'élèves qui passent le bac
plus les chances seront élevés
d'observer des équerres de répartition
importante et par conséquent des écarts
de réussite au baccalauréat par rapport
à la population à contrario un
échantillonnage large par exemple 10 000
élèves permettra d'approximer avec plus
de certitudes les paramètres de la
population un niveau agrégé prenant en
compte l'ensemble des variations
aléatoires la variance
d'échantillonnages offre un indicateur
global qui résume les cas escomptés
entre le taux de réussite constaté dans
un échantillon de nez et le taux
constaté dans la population cette
équerre connu à travers la loi binomiale
et proportionnelle au nombre d'individus
dans l'échantillon et au taux de
réussite de la population alors il faut
s'accrocher
et là on est à un moment de l'article où
il faut pas abandonner il faut juste
poser la question mais qu'est-ce que la
loi binomiale
et on va aller voir un petit article
un petit cours que j'ai retrouvé qui est
bien sympa pour nous expliquer ça quoi
alors moi je vous l'ai dit je suis pas
un pronom plus de la stats j'essaie
juste de progresser aussi dans tout ça
et donc en faisant le titre recherche et
en accrochant finalement j'ai pu
comprendre le sens de l'article hop je
vous présente ceci et donc là c'est
juste l'université Paris Ouest Nanterre
La Défense qui nous propose
une petite synthèse sur ce qu'est la loi
binomiale
voilà et la loi binolien binomiale c'est
aussi un test que l'on peut faire un
test statistique pour voir si notre si
les résultats qu'on obtient sont sont
biaisés ou pas biaisés ça veut dire
qu'il y a un billet qui ne sont pas
corrects alors l'exemple qu'on pourrait
prendre c'est je lance un dé et
j'obtiens tout le temps des un mais
est-ce que je peux me poser la question
le fait d'obtenir que D1 si je fais 20
lancer et que j'obtiens 20 fois un 1
c'est que peut-être que mon d défectueux
qu'il est qu'il scindé de tricheur ou ou
qu'on l'habidouillait pour qu'il puisse
toujours afficher des 1 donc voilà si je
fais 20 lancer c'est pas normal en
quelque sorte si vous voulez d'obtenir
que des 1 donc c'est ça qui va nous
permettre de mesurer le test binomial
alors on pourrait le faire plus
facilement le test binomial vous voyez
be c'est souvent quand il y a deux
possibilités donc par exemple lancer
d'une pièce sur pile ou face alors tu
peux lancer une fois sur un lancer tu
vas avoir 100% tellement de chance
d'obtenir un pile ou une face enfin tu
as 50% de chance mais une fois que tu as
ton pile ou ton face je veux dire tu as
100% de pile ou de face dans ton un
lancer si tu prends sans lancer et que
tu obtiens 100 % de face ou 100 % de
pile c'est qu'il y a un problème si tu
veux c'est ça que te permettre de voir
le test binomial parce que plus tu vas
faire de lancer de ta pièce mais plus tu
auras de chance d'arriver à du 55 ans si
la probabilité d'avoir le pile ou le
fasse c'est 55 ans bon dans le cas d'une
pièce c'est 55 ans donc tu vois tu dois
plus tu augmentes ton nombre plus tu vas
approcher de la probabilité
de de ton échantillon quoi
alors je vais peut-être assez maladroit
dans mon explication mais ici vous allez
voir on va on va revenir sur tout ça
lorsque la taille de l'échantillon est
très petite on peut envisager de faire
un test exact les tests exacts sont ceux
pour lesquels on peut sous l'hypothèse
H0 calculer la probabilité exacte
d'obtenir les valeurs qui ont été
observées on n'utilise pas de
statistiques ou de variables de décision
on compare directement la probabilité de
rejeter l'hypothèse au risque alpha s'il
est très improbable sous l'hypothèse 0
on peut obtenir les données observées à
leur rejette l'hypothèse nulle le test
binomial est un test exact utilisé dans
le cas d'une variable aléatoire et en
deux Mobilis modalités ici c'est
parfaitement ce qu'on cherche puisque il
se taux de réussite au bac tu rates ou
tu réussis ton bac et donc l'auteur de
l'article les auteurs de l'article nous
proposent de faire un test binomial
on va voir son fonctionnement sur un
exemple et là vous allez bien comprendre
pour un test bilatéral l'hypothèse nulle
et que le nombre d'observations dans une
classe est conforme à une probabilité
théorique connue d'avance donc on sait
ici dans le cadre du baccalauréat on
sait le taux de réussite on connaît le
taux de réussite global si tu veux et on
a même un modèle qu'on nous propose
donc on peut appliquer
donc l'hypothèse nulle et que le nombre
d'observations dans une classe est
inférieur ou égale à la valeur attendue
et l'hypothèse alternative qui est
strictement bon exemple c'est surtout ça
qui m'intéresse on joue à pile ou face
15 fois et on obtient 3 fois face
peut-on dire au seuil 5% que la pièce
est truquée donc ici 5% c'est juste le
degré d'erreur qu'on va accepter on va
considérer qu'en dessous de 5%, ça sera
le résultat du texte du texte et bien le
test n'est pas fructueux ça veut dire
que la pièce est probablement truquée
alors je vais vous montrer d'autres
choses si on tape juste test binomial
sur sur le net
je vais aller voir ce wiki
c'est pas ici j'avais vu j'avais vu un
truc mais je sais plus voilà c'est ça
c'était juste sur la synthèse en fait
ici graphiquement voici les probabilités
que j'ai quand je fais un lancer de
pièces si ça c'est le nombre de lancer
plus non pardon c'est pas le nombre de
lanciers c'est le nombre de fois où je
peux obtenir
pile ou face mais tu vois que sur un
nombre de lancés je peux très peu
probable que
j'obtienne que des piles ou que des
faces je vais souvent sur un nombre de
lancés importants être plutôt sur des
valeurs qui vont approximer 55 ans quoi
c'est un peu ça que ça veut dire le
texte le texte binomial
voilà alors on vient
à l'article
ah oui non je voulais vous montrer aussi
une chose on va juste regarder
comment ça se calcule et là sur les
tableurs tout simplement Google sheet
on a en fait
une formule loi binomiale si je me
trompe pas
attendez on va aller la rechercher
autrement insertion fonction stats
loi loi loi binomiale donc voilà ici on
a une formule qui va directement nous
calculer qui va nous faire le test en
fait et ça c'est vachement pratique
parce que vous allez comprendre comment
ça marche donc ici nombre de succès je
vais reprendre l'exemple qui est donné
dans le
dans la fiche de cours qui était ici
exemple donc on joue à pile ou face 15
fois et on obtient 3 passes donc ici on
va mettre le nombre de succès ces trois
faces
le nombre d'essai il joue 15 fois
la probabilité de succès c'est 0,5
puisque on a la moitié depuis la moitié
de face normalement et ici c'est juste
mettre un c'est juste un paramètre
supplémentaire et donc là j'obtiens un
score si je le mets en pourcentage de
1,76 donc 1,76 on est bien en dessous
des 5% qu'on s'était fixés et donc là
sur ce coup-là ça veut dire qu'il y a
une probabilité ça veut pas dire que la
pièce est truquée mais ça veut dire que
c'est un peu chelou quoi voilà ça c'est
vraiment un test binomial c'est comme ça
qu'on le fait et donc normalement ici
ils obtiennent justement le score de 1,7
1,76 voilà ici ils font tout le calcul
mais vous voyez que nous on doit pas
être statisticien nous on doit juste
comprendre et en utilisant le tableur on
retrouve directement ce 1,76 voilà on a
compris comment fonctionne le test
binomial si on est en dessous des 5%, ça
veut dire que il y a du bruit il y a il
y a un truc qui est pas normal quoi si
tu veux ça va donc ça c'est assez
important
à comprendre
hop on va revenir
sur l'article
et donc en faisant ce je veux dire ce
Beth texte mais il est pas plus bête
qu'un autre en faisant ce test
statistique on peut déjà
évaluer ces ivals on va évaluer
l'évaluation
pour voir si c'est si c'est un bon
indicateur ou s'il y a plein de facteurs
en fait qui sont pas pris en compte
par rapport à la loi binomiale des
critiques ci-dessus la méthodologie des
ivales présente l'intérêt de reconnaître
que les lycées ne sont pas
représentatifs de la population en
raison de facteurs exogènes donc c'est
pour ça qu'il y a un modèle qui est
proposé par un taux prédit par un modèle
statistique qui prennent en compte les
caractéristiques du public accueillies
dans chaque lycée ce faisant la valeur
ajoutée des lycées est associée à
l'équerre entre le taux constaté le taux
prédit le raisonnement étant que cet
écart reflète l'action éducative du
lycée pourtant le fait que le taux
observé soit soumis à une variance
d’échantillonnage nous indique que cet
équerre est en partie du moins le fruit
d'une erreur d'échantillonnage cela
indique que la méthode de calcul
actuellement utilisée confond deux
sources de variance de la valeur ajoutée
l'une due à l'action éducative l'autre
dû au bruit de l'erreur
d'échantillonnage donc en fait l'action
éducative elle est bien dans le résultat
quoi
l'effet d'établissement il impacte quand
même le taux de réussite au baccalauréat
mais en même temps on a d'autres
facteurs qui interviennent c'est ce
bruit et en fait on entend évaluer cette
mincie mais en fait on évalue demain
quoi si vous voulez
le fait que les indicateurs de
performance contiennent du bruit n'est
pas surprenant en soi analyser un
phénomène suppose bien de ce centrer sur
ces traits essentiels et dans l'ignorer
d'autres plus secondaires un modèle
c'est une simplification afin de
simplifier la modélisation de l'objet et
donc comme tu utilises un modèle
forcément tu n'as pas la réalité et donc
il y a forcément du bruit donc c'est un
peu logique tu vois
toute modélisation statistique comporte
ainsi une forme d'approximation qui
laisse de la place à l'incertitude dans
les estimations cette simplification de
la réalité peut néanmoins s'appellerait
problématique lorsque le bruit devient
très pondérant par rapport à
l'information fournie par le modèle dans
cette perspective il convient de mesurer
l'ampleur du bruit contenu dans les
indicateurs de performance d'après la
loi binomiale il est possible
d'identifier la présence de ce bruit en
testant si l'écart entre le taux prédit
et constaté de la performance d'un lycée
ne diffère pas pour un seuil de
significativité de données de 5% comme
on l'a fait tout à l'heure pour le test
de la pièce de l'écart à ce compter
d'après
la variance d'échantillonnage dans le
cas d'un écart non significatif
supérieur à 5%, la valeur ajoutée sera
alors considérée comme étant confondus
avec l'erreur d'échantillonnage c'est à
dire oui la question étant alors de
savoir dans quelle mesure les valeurs
ajoutées s'avèrent
voilà vous avez compris l'essentiel ici
et maintenant je vais plus lire
l'article je vais juste vous montrer
certains éléments je vais repasser sur
l'autre vue
et donc là l'auteur nous propose
quelques tableaux et notamment ici on va
voir des graphiques qui vont permettre
de comprendre certaines choses
ici on a les valeurs ajoutées de
réussite au baccalauréat sur les
sessions 2014 à 2016 parmi les lisses
les lycées de l'académie de Grenoble
donc pour réaliser leur test ils vont se
baser sur sur ce qui fait dans la ce qui
se fait dans l'académie de Grenoble et
ici on a différents figuré on a des
petits triangles
et où nous explique comment il faut lire
ça
61 lycées dont la valeur ajoutée n'est
jamais significative au seuil de 5% les
triangles indiquent la valeur ajoutée de
chaque lycée en fonction de la session
de baccalauréat aucune des valeurs
ajoutées affichées ne significativement
différente de l'action du hasard test
binomiale avec P qui est supérieur à 5
%. les droites pleines esquisses la
trajectoire des valeurs ajoutées qui
changent le signe au cours du temps de
positif à négatif ou de négative à
positif et inversement en pointillés
donc là on voit quand il y a d'une année
à l'autre on peut même avoir de très
gros écarts entre des lycées forcément
s'il y a du bruit leur action
n'est pas forcément reconnue à bon
escient
et donc ici voilà on va avoir parfois
des écarts assez importants valeur
ajoutée des lycées dans la réussite au
Baccalauréat en fonction de la
définition brute ou corrigée de la
valeur ajoutée parce qu'ils vont nous
proposer une manière de corriger cette
valeur ajoutée et donc par exemple ici
vous avez le triangle du bas
qui était ici en fait eux ils proposent
en prenant en compte
certains éléments de rectifier ça et de
l'obtenir ici
et vous voyez qu'on se rapproche en fait
du résultat réel le résultat réel c'est
le point
donc ce que je dis
donc 57 il ressorts à partir de la
population de lycée les triangles
renvoient à l'ival brut les points à
l'ival corrigés les triangles de
couleurs claires indiquent les ivals
brutes significatifs à 5% d'après le
test binomial les triangles de couleurs
noir brutes non significatifs
l'intervalle de confiance en 95%
correspond aux valeurs de l'ival
corrigées à travers les simulations
donc on voit qu'on se rapproche tout
doucement d'une moyenne et que la
correction permet de revenir à des
valeurs beaucoup plus standard
alors comment est-ce qu'il corrige on va
voir ça
voilà j'en étais là
les résultats de cette étude contribuent
à révéler une situation pour le moins
équivoque alors que l'institution
scolaire enjoint les acteurs éducatifs à
fonder leur action sur la preuve des
indicateurs de performance cette preuve
s'avère en partie fondée sur du bruit
statistique cette situation a pour
conséquence de rendre incertaine la
prise d'information quand elle
l'efficacité des actions éducatives et
sur cette base de rendre le pilotage
éducatif tributaire du hasard afin
d'illustrer les erreurs de jugement qui
peuvent résulter du bruit nous projetons
les taux prédits et observés de la
réussite à la session 2016 estimée sur
le même jeu de données que précédemment
du côté droit du graphique 2 je vais
vous le montrer après nous observons que
le lycée 86 présente une valeur ajoutée
élevée de l'ordre de 4,4 points
signifiant que son taux de réussite
observé
et plus de 4 points au dessus du taux
qui étaient prédit par le modèle
au seul vu de cette valeur l'action de
ce lycée paraît tout à fait efficace
pour soutenir la réussite scolaire donc
on attendait
95,6% et ils obtiennent 100% de
bacheliers waouh ils ont super bien
travaillé dans ce livre c'est là quoi
ils ont vraiment mis à des trucs en
place pour aider leurs élèves au seul vu
de cette valeur l'action de ce lycée
paraît tout à fait efficace pour
soutenir la réussite scolaire pourtant
cette valeur ajoutée n'est en fait pas
significative d'après le test binomial
car l'effectif de ce lycée est
relativement faible il y a 77 élèves
seulement et induit une erreur
d'échantillonnage importante l'écart
entre les deux taux ne peut donc être
pas être attribué à l'efficacité du
lycée parce que le risque qu'il soit dû
au hasard et trop élevé ça veut pas dire
qu'il est du hasard mais il y a un
risque que ça soit dû au hasard
donc ça je peux vous montrer ici
le graphique donc cette graphique 2
donc il nous parlait du lycée 86 on voit
qu'il est là il y a de taux de réussite
prédit donc ils étaient un tour voilà de
réussite de plus ou moins 96 et ils
arrivent à 100%
donc là on se dit waouh quoi ils ont
surperformé
mais en fait voilà quand on calcule il y
a il y a une possibilité selon le test
binomial que ça ne soit dû au hasard
quoi comme on avait fait avec la pièce
tout à l'heure ça c'est un peu l'idée
en terme de pilotage une valeur ajoutée
broutée par le hasard et par essence
inexplicable et non informatique
pourtant elle a toutes les chances
d'être interprétée par les équipes
éducatives comme la conséquence de leur
action et cela pour deux raisons
principales ouais super les gars on a
super bien travaillé mais en fait c'est
juste qu'on n'est pas sûr que ça soit
vraiment eux qui soit à l'origine de ces
résultats là quoi d'une part
l'indicateur de performance incorpore
bel et bien pour une part inconnue
l'effet de leur pratique d'autre part
les humains ont tendance spontanément à
ne pas voir l'effet du hasard dans des
événements ou pourtant il peut y avoir
une part prédominante on va toujours sur
interpréter le match aujourd'hui oui si
c'est passé ça c'est parce que il y a eu
ceci mais en fait c'est parfois juste la
faute t'as pas de chance ou la la chance
des éléments tout à fait extérieurs qui
ont fait que on en arrive à cette
situation là quoi
c'est de la superstition en fait nous
sommes des superstitieux chroniques les
travaux sur le jugement humain ont en
effet bien montré notre faible niveau
d'intuition statistique défaut de prise
en compte du hasard et à l'inverse notre
propension à établir des associations
causales fondées sur l'accessibilité
immédiate de l'information
ainsi les acteurs éducatifs auront
tendance des billets de biocognitifs
auront tendance à interpréter la valeur
ajoutée d'un lycée
plutôt qu'une explication difficile
d'accès
donc plutôt leur action à eux que
simplement la faute a pas de chance quoi
dans les pires des scénarios qui
concernent 37% des lycées quand même
dans leur étude l'effet du hasard pourra
contribuer à produire des ivals positifs
une année négatifs l'année suivante ce
que je vous montre tout à l'heure pour
un même lycée les acteurs éducatifs se
retrouvant ainsi contraints
d'interpréter des fluctuations positives
ou négatives de leur rival dans une
spirale d'auto-évaluation éprouvante à
valider ou à valider successivement leur
pratique indépendamment de l'efficacité
réelle de ces dernières donc en fait ils
vont consacrer leur énergie à des choses
voilà qui qui ne sont pas interprétables
parce que trop complexe en termes de
facteurs
en tout cas en termes de facteurs non
identifiés
donc après il propose soit de corriger
ces ivals brutes comme on l'a vu
non de garder les ivals brutes de garder
ses scores en précisant s'ils sont
significatifs ou pas donc eux ils
proposent simplement et puis il propose
aussi de faire des ivals corrigées où là
on va rectifier comme on l'avait vu sur
un graphique ou la correction par le
paramètre de fidélité permet alors de
ramener l'effet du lycée depuis sa
valeur contaminée par l'effet du hasard
à une valeur débarrassée de cet effet
qui reflète mieux en moyenne l'action
spécifique du lycée
voilà
on en a fini avec cet article
l'ensemble de ces résultats permet donc
d'affirmer que les indicateurs de
performance français nécessite sans
doute une révision de leur stratégie
d'estimation qui puisse offrir des
indicateurs plus informatifs quant à
l'action réelle des lycées
un renforcement plus substantiel
consisterait néanmoins à interroger les
objectifs institutionnels visés par les
indicateurs de performance on peut
également s'interroger sur la pertinence
de l'accès au baccalauréat comme unique
du mention éducatif visé par les ivals
voilà un article qui vous montre alors
on n'est pas vraiment sur une démarche
scolaire des sciences sociales comme on
peut l'expliquer au cours ou comme je le
fais au cours mais c'est pour vous
montrer aussi l'important c'est
statistiques
dans les séances sociales et notamment
vous retrouvez beaucoup de statistiques
quand vous lisez cette revue française
sociologie ou c'est toujours très
exigeant il y a des articles parfois
vraiment qui sont très très denses et où
il faut vraiment prendre son temps et se
documenter en tout cas quand on est
quelqu'un qui n'est pas au fait de la
recherche et de ces outils statistiques
voilà je vous remercie pour votre
attention et je vous dis à très bientôt
pour une nouvelle lecture ou une
nouvelle vidéo consacrée aux sciences
sociales à très bientôt sur la société
merci merci